- Hello, Believe Nation and
the start of a new series
we're calling the Did You Know series.
Our first video is going to
be on nine surprising facts
about Tony Robbins.
Hope you enjoy.
(loud swooshing)
Fact number one, he started in
the personal development field
when he was working for Jim Rohn
at the age of 17 selling
his motivational seminars.
- I was working for Jim Rohn, the speaker,
and I was 17 years old.
I had long hair, minestrone
soup acne on my face
and I was trying to call on
Bear Stearns type of people
and convince them why they should go to
this man's seminar and be more successful.
I was driving a 1968 Volkswagen
that I had earned at
$40 a week as a janitor.
The only way I did it was
park far from the building
and then go in and I love people
and I believe when I put myself in state
and I was able to influence people
that were far more successful
than I was at the time.
I had a dear, dear friend
and mentor named Jim Rohn
who was my teacher when
I was 17 years old.
He's somebody that I sent out some videos.
I'll probably attach
some things to this video
or another one about him just
to honor him and his teachings.
But he gave me a way of looking at life
that allowed me to not
ask life would be easier,
but to ask that I be better.
He got me to realize that
the secret to life was
to work harder on myself
than my job or anything else
because then I'd have
something to give people.
And he really shaped me
and he just passed away
and I was thinking wow, I'm
going to be 49 years old.
I met him when I was 17.
Think of the fact that my
journey is just beginning
and think of all the impact that just
a couple ideas had on my life
and want to really continue to to do that
for you or anybody you care about, so.
- Fact number two, what
made his early career
was when he challenged a psychiatrist
saying that he could cure
someone's snake phobia
in a matter of minutes.
- So, there's a famous
story about something
I've forgotten now, but it was somebody
had some kind of phobia, what was it?
- Snake phobia, yeah, yeah.
- Snake phobia.
And the psychiatrist said
it'd take seven years
and you did it in 15 minutes.
- Yeah.
But what made my career was that
I was attacked by the psychiatrist
on the radio saying you're
a liar, your a charlatan.
People like you should not
be allowed on the radio.
You can't do this and so,
I was a real rebel frankly,
and I was, like, in his face saying,
great, are you a scientist?
If you are then test your hypothesis.
Give me your patient.
I'll be at the Holiday Inn tomorrow night.
So, it was like this shootout
and it was like a movie.
He brought her, I wiped it out,
I wrapped the snake around her.
A phobia is an uncontrollable
physical response
to some stimulus, you
know, it's not just fear.
It's shaking, spitting.
- Right, right.
- At the end she was totally fine.
He worked on her for seven years.
So, that became my
signature, was to challenge.
And then gradually I grew 'cause
I was really just trying to prove
to everybody and myself as well
that I was worthy rather than maturing
a little bit and just knowing there
are skill sets that are
valuable for everybody.
- Fact number three, in the 1980s
he used television infomercials
to promote his books and programs.
- [Announcer] Do you want
to establish good credit?
Now you can thanks to
this exciting new program
from Tony Robbins.
- Hi, I'm Tony Robbins.
I'm the author of the
national bestselling book
Unlimited Power.
For over ten years now, I've helped over
a million people that take
control of their life,
mentally, emotionally,
physically and financially.
And so many people I meet have
pain in the area of credit.
If you're one of the 40 million
Americans who really needs
a Visa card, we have a
solution that's guaranteed.
I've created the easiest,
most affordable way
to guarantee you a Visa card immediately.
Our program will also show you how
to take control of your
own financial freedom.
- [Announcer] For your
$2.99 per minute call
you'll receive information
about how to get
your very own Visa card
with no deposit required.
You'll hear Tony Robbins seven
secrets to financial success
plus receive Tony's powerful audio tape.
Tony Robbin's program offers you
the easiest, most affordable
way to receive your Visa card.
With 14.9% interest, no deposit required
and guaranteed acceptance
or your money back.
Call this number now to take advantage
of this exciting new offer.
- Fact number four, he did
a cameo roll as himself
in the film Shallow Hal
starring Jack Black.
- Hey, it's you.
You're the TV guru guy.
- Yes, Tony Robbins, please to meet you.
- Yeah.
- Well, it was interesting the
Farley brothers are friends
and fans and they're
brilliant, funny, crazy guys.
And they invited me to
participate in the movie
and I didn't turn them
down, I just said no
because it just wasn't for me.
And when they brought me
the script I was moved
by it because the message
is about inner-beauty
and not being a surface-driven person,
which is part of what my life's about.
Hypothetical situation,
which do you prefer,
a girlfriend missing one
breast or half a brain?
- Ew, toughie.
- And then I found out that the story
was written by a man who'd bought
my personal power audio
program off of television,
off an infomercial years ago.
So, I said, yeah, I want to do this.
And I wasn't originally in the script.
They were using this, like,
seance guy to do this.
You've got a pattern of looking at women
and judging them by the exterior.
You know, they wrote the script
and none of it was really me and I said,
you know, I've memorized this
and I'm very respectful,
you put me in the middle
of this movie as a central character,
but this is not what I'd say.
So, I'll do what you want,
but can I just show you what I really do?
And they go, Tony, it's a movie.
I said just let me try.
- Can you think of one specific time when
you were really shallow?
- Oh yeah, I got one.
- Think about that, ready?
- I got a good one.
- Devils come out.
- What the hell are you
doing, banana hands?
- So, that heeled scene when
I smack him on the head,
he had no idea that was coming.
They had no idea it was coming.
In fact, they laughed
so hard when it happened
that his reactions are not fake reactions,
they're actual reactions.
They were real reactions 'cause
he didn't know it was coming.
And then they shot the thing 15 angles
'cause everybody was laughing so hard
cameras were shaking and everything else.
But that's my approach.
My approach is jar people
into reality quickly,
not talk about things.
It was a great privilege
to be part of the film
and I have no desire to be an actor,
but I'm grateful that I was
part of that great little story.
- Fact number five, U.S.
President Bill Clinton
called him before he was impeached.
- I get a phone call
where a child is suicidal
or the President of
the United States calls
and says they're going to
impeach me in the morning.
What should I do?
- So that actually happened?
- That actually happened.
- Bill Clinton called you the night before
in 1998 and said Tony,
they may be impeaching me
in the morning, what should I do.
What an extraordinary position
of responsibility that you have.
- Well, I'm sure I'm not
the only person he called.
(laughing)
- You're one of the people he called.
- By any stretch and yes.
- Just step back for a moment.
That moment, how did you feel?
Despite all these incredible
things you've experienced,
to have the President of your country
call you in his great hour of need.
- If you're thinking about yourself
in a moment like that
you can't really serve.
So, then it'd be all about you.
What I felt was a sense of responsibility
and I also felt I need
to sell him straight
of what I really believed.
And I knew he was going
to get different opinions
and I don't really talk about what
I do with someone unless
they speak about it,
but I did speak at that point
and said, frankly, you
know, you're not going to
be impeached in the
morning, easy for me to say,
I'm not in your position.
It's just politically
it's not going to happen.
But what you have to decide is
what's your legacy going to be.
What's your outcome?
Because you have to decide what
you're going to be able to say
that people at home can
tell their children about.
You have to look at
what you can do legally.
But if I were you I'd be
doing what you know is right
and nothing less than that process.
'Cause you want to be able
to look yourself in the face.
- Fact number six, the best advice
he ever got was also from Jim Rohn.
- What's the best piece of
advice you've ever gotten?
- God, that's so much, but I think one of
the most important ones
was early in my life
one of my mentors named Jim Rohn said,
"Tony, all you have to focus on your life
is find a way to add more
value than anybody else does
and you'll never have
to worry about anything.
Be the person that does more for others
and life will just be
anything you want out of it,"
really is what it is, so.
And he also said the way to do that
is every day work harder on
yourself than anything else.
'Cause if you become more
intelligent, more valuable,
more skilled you can add
more value to other people.
- Fact number seven, he wants to feed
over one billion people over Thanksgiving.
- You were growing up, you
were really poor, right?
- Extremely.
- Extremely poor.
- We had no money for
Thanksgiving for food.
It's part of why last year I
started feeding when I was 17.
I started feeding families
since I was fed when I was 11.
And I fed two families,
literally, and it was so moving,
I said I'm going to
double it, I went to four
and then to eight and
then it was, like, a game
to see could I reach more people.
And then I started with some of employees
and then eventually got to
a million people a year,
then two million and
then I started matching
my foundation with two million.
So, for 12 years I fed
four million people a year.
And then when I was writing this book
I'm interviewing, if you can imagine,
all these people started with nothing
and are multi-billionaires.
At the same time,
congress cut food stamps,
called SNAP now, but it
was food stamps originally,
by eight billion dollars.
So, it's the equivalent,
to give ya an idea,
of every family that's being supported
giving up all their meals one week
out of every month for 12 months.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- So, I decided I wanted
to do something about it,
so I got a five million
dollar advance for the book.
I gave all the money to Feeding America
and then I said if I want
to feed 100 million people
what do I got to do, so I
wrote a much bigger check
and now I'm so, we did 102
million people last year,
but now I'm going to do
100 million again this year
and I got a plan to feed a billion people
over the next ten years, so.
It's so full circle from where I began.
It's crazy and it's an
incredible privilege
to be able to make a difference like that.
- Fact number eight, he uses Cryotherapy
to help his body recover
from being on stage all day.
- I'm like an athlete, you got
to train your nervous system.
Besides physically working out,
I also train my mind to do and
my emotions to do what's most difficult
and I do that in all kinds of ways.
I like to play at my edge.
You know, that's how you get better.
So, I put high demands on myself.
But the first thing I do
every morning as part of
that ritual is I jump in
a jacuzzi which loosens
the muscles and then I jump
in freezing cold water.
I have a cold plunge, if you would.
It's 57 degrees and I
drop into that thing.
I also for recover
sake, I use Cryotherapy,
which was developed in Europe.
It's amazing.
A lot of athletes around
the world are using it now.
And it lowers your body
temperature using nitrogens.
So, there's no water on
you or you would freeze
to death or you would burn.
By using these gases it
brings the temperature down
in your body down to minus 225 fahrenheit,
which is my, well, for three minutes.
And what it does is it like
resets your whole nervous system
and it takes all the
inflammation out of your body.
So, I'm on stage and I'll do 27 miles
on my most intense day
of a three day program,
so I'm doing, like, multiple
days of Ultramarathon.
'Cause I'm not standing there talking.
I mean, people would not come,
people won't sit for a three hour movie
someone spend 300 million
dollars on to make for two hours.
If they're going to stay with
me for 50 hours over a weekend,
I got to deliver, right?
And I got the Paul Tudor Jones
of the world in there, the Oprah Winfeys.
Oprah tells me Tony I love ya,
but I can't sit anywhere
for more than two hours
and at the end of 12 hours she's standing
in her chair going on camera
"this is one of the greatest
experiences of my life".
Well, to do that, you
aren't standing still.
I'm plunging the audience,
I'm doing things.
I'm spontaneous, so that's a lot of miles.
So, I'm literally doing one marathon
and I go into this machine
and three minutes later
I come out and the next day it's like
instead of all these
aches and pains and tears
I'm recovered, so.
I'm always looking for technology
that can enhance my ability to perform
and produce greater results
and also stay healthy.
- And fact number nine,
he has one of the three
most popular TED Talk videos of all time
for his talk "Why We Do What We Do".
- Thank you.
I have to tell you I'm both
challenged and excited.
My excitement is I get a
chance to give something back.
My challenge is the shortest seminar
I usually do is 50 hours.
(laughing)
I'm not exaggerating, I
do weekends and what I do,
I do even more than that
obviously, coach people,
but into emersion because
how'd you learn language?
You didn't learn it by
just learning principals.
You got in it and you did it
so often that it became real.
And the bottom line of why I'm here,
besides being crazy mo-fo is that
I'm really in a position, I'm not here
to motivate you obviously,
you don't need that.
A lot of times that's
what people think I do
and it's the furthest thing from it.
What happens though is people say to me
"well, I don't need any
motivation" and I say
well, that's interesting,
that's not what I do.
I'm the why guy.
I want to know why you do what you do.
What is your motive for action?
What is it that drives
you in your life today,
not ten years ago, are you
running the same pattern?
Because I believe that the invisible force
of internal drive activated is
the most important thing in the world.
I'm here because I believe
emotion is the force of life.
All of us here have great minds.
You know, most of us
here have great minds.
Right?
(laughing)
I don't know if I'm in that category,
but we all know how to
think and with our minds
we can rationalize anything,
we can make anything happen.
We can, I agree with what
was described a few days ago
about this idea that people
work in their self-interest,
but we all know that
that's bullshit at times.
You don't work in your
self-interest all the time.
Because when emotion comes into it
the wiring changes in
the way it functions.
And so it's wonderful for
us to think intellectually
about how the life of the world is
and especially those who are very smart.
We can play this game in our head,
but I really want to
know what's driving you
and what I'd like to
maybe invite you to do
by the end of this talk is explore
where you are today, for two reasons.
One, so that you can contribute more
and two, so that hopefully
we can not just understand
other people more, but
maybe appreciate them more
and create the kinds of connections
that can stop some of the challenges
that we face in our society today.
They're only going to get magnified
by the very technology
that's connecting us.
'Cause it's making us intersect
and that intersection
doesn't always create
the view of everybody
now understands everybody
and everybody appreciates everybody.
So, I've had an obsession
basically for 30 years.
And that obsession has been what makes
the difference in the
quality of people's lives?
What makes a difference
in their performance
'cause that's what I got hired to do.
I got to produce a result now.
That's what I've done for 30 years.
I get the phone call when the athlete
is burning down on national television
and they were ahead by five strokes
and now they can't get back on the course.
And I got to do something right now
to get the result or nothing matters.
I get the phone call when
the child is going to
commit suicide and I got
to do something right now.
And in 29 years, I'm
very grateful to tell ya,
I've never lost one in 29 years.
That doesn't mean I won't some day,
but I haven't done it.
And the reason is an understanding
of these human needs that I
want to talk to you about.
So, when I get those
calls about performance
that's one thing, like
how to you make a change?
But also I'm looking to see what is it
that's shaping that person's
ability to contribute,
to do something beyond themselves.
So, maybe the real question is, you know,
I look at life and say
there's two master lessons.
One is there's the science of achievement,
which almost everyone in this room
is mastered to in an amazing stent.
That's how do you take the invisible
and make it visible, right?
How do you take what you're dreaming about
and make it happen?
(snapping fingers)
Whether it be your
business, your contribution
to society, money, whatever it is for you.
Your body, your family.
But the other lesson of
life that is rarely mastered
is the art of fulfillment.
'Cause science is easy, right?
We know the rules, you write the code,
you follow the, and you get the result.
Once you know the game, you just,
you know, you up the anti, don't you?
But when it comes to
fulfillment, that's an art.
And the reason is it's about appreciation
and it's about contribution.
You can only fill so much by yourself.
So, I've had an interesting laboratory
to try to answer the
question of the real question
which is what's the
difference in somebody's life
if you look at somebody like those people
that you've given everything to.
Like, all the resources
they say they need.
You gave them not a
hundred dollar computer,
you gave them the best computer.
You gave them love, you gave them joy.
You were there to comfort them.
And those people very often,
and you know some of them I'm sure
and that the rest of their life with all
this love, education, money and background
spending their life going
in and out of rehab.
And then you meet people that
have been through ultimate pain.
Psychologically, sexually,
spiritually, emotionally abused
and not always, but often they become
some of the people that
contribute the most to society.
So, the question we got
to ask ourselves really is
what is it, what is it that shapes us?
And we live in a therapy culture.
Most of us don't do that,
but the culture's a therapy culture.
And what I mean by that is the
mindset that we are our past.
And everybody in this room, you wouldn't
be in this room if you bought that theory,
but the most of society
thinks biography is destiny.
The past equals the future.
And of course it does if you live there,
but what people in this room know
and what we have to
remind ourselves though,
'cause you can know
something intellectually.
You can know what to do and
then not use it, not apply it.
So, really what we got to remind ourselves
is decision is the ultimate power.
That's what it really is.
Now, when you ask people, you know,
have you failed to achieve something.
How many have every failed to achieve
something significant in your life, say I.
(audience saying "I")
Thanks for the interaction
on a high level there.
(laughing)
But if you ask people why
didn't you achieve something,
somebody who's working for you, you know,
or a partner or even yourself.
When you fail to achieve a goal
what's the reason people
say they fail to achieve?
What do they tell ya?
Don't have the, didn't know enough.
Didn't have the knowledge, didn't have the
(audience shouting out)
money.
Didn't have the
(audience shouting out)
time.
Didn't have the
(audience shouting out)
technology.
You know, I didn't have the right manager.
(audience shouting out)
Didn't have the Supreme Court.
(laughing)
(applauding)
And what do all those, including
the Supreme Court have in common?
(laughing)
They are a claim to you missing resources
and they may be accurate.
You may not have the money.
You may not have the Supreme Court,
but that is not the defining factor.
(laughing)
(applauding)
And you correct me if I'm wrong,
the defining factor is never resources,
it's resourcefulness and
what I mean specifically,
rather than just some phrase,
is if you have emotion, human emotion,
something that I experience from you
day before yesterday that is at a level
that is as profound as
I've ever experienced,
then if you'd communicated
with that emotion
I believe you would have
beat his ass and won.
(applauding)
But how easy for me to
tell him what he should do.
(laughing)
Idiot Robbins.
But I know when we watched the debates,
when we watched the debate at that time,
there were emotions that
blocked people's ability
to get this man's intellect and capacity
and the way it came across
to some people in that day.
'Cause I know people that wanted to vote
in your direction and
didn't and I was upset.
But there was emotion that was there.
How many know what I'm talking about here?
Say I.
(audience saying "I")
So, emotion is it and if
we get the right emotion
we can get ourselves to do anything.
We can get through it.
If you're creative enough,
playful enough, fun enough
can you get through to anybody, yes or no?
(audience saying "yes")
If you don't have the money,
but you're creative and determined
enough you find the way.
So, this is the ultimate resource,
but this is not the story
that people tell us, right?
The story people tell us is
a bunch of different stories.
They tell us we don't have the resources,
but ultimately, if you take a look here,
flip it up if you would,
they say what are all the
reasons they have in common,
we've said that, next one please.
He's broken my pattern,
that son of a bitch.
(laughing)
But I appreciated the
energy, I'll tell ya that.
(laughing)
What determines your resources?
We've said decisions shape
destiny, which is my focus here.
If decisions shape destiny,
what determines it is three decisions.
What are you going to focus on?
Right now, you have to decide
what you're going to focus on.
In this second, consciously
or unconsciously.
The minute you decide to focus
on something you got to give it a meaning.
And whatever that meaning
is produces emotion.
Is this the end or the beginning?
Is God punishing me or rewarding me
or is this the role of the dice?
And emotion then creates what
we're going to do, or the action.
So, think about your own life,
the decisions that have
shaped your destiny.
And that sounds really heavy,
but in the last five
or 10 years, 15 years,
how about some decisions have you made,
that if you made a different decision
your life would be completely different?
How many can think of one, honestly.
Better or worse, say I.
(audience saying "I")
So, the bottom line is maybe
it was where to go to work
and you met the love of your life there.
Maybe it was a career decision.
I know the Google geniuses I saw here,
I mean, I understand that their decision
was to sell their technology at first.
What if they made that decision versus
to build their own culture?
How would the world be different?
How would their lives be
different, their impact?
The history of our world
is these decisions.
When a woman stands up and says
"no I won't go to the back of the bus"
she didn't just affect her life.
That decision shaped our culture.
Or someone standing in front of a tank.
Or being in a position
like Lance Armstrong
and someone says to you,
you got testicular cancer.
That's pretty tough for any male,
especially if you ride a bike.
(laughing)
You got it in your brain,
you got it in your lungs,
but what was his decision
on what to focus on?
Different than most
people, what did it mean?
It wasn't the end, it was the beginning.
What am I going to do?
He goes off and wins seven championships
he never once won before the cancer
because he got emotional
fitness, psychological strength.
That's the difference in human beings
that I've seen of the three
million that I've been around.
'Cause that's about my lab,
I've had three million people
from 80 different countries that I've had
the chance to interact with
over the last 29 years.
And after awhile, patterns become obvious.
You see that South America and Africa
may be connected in a certain way, right?
Other people say "oh, that
sounds ridiculous", it's simple.
So what shapes Lance, what shapes you
two invisible forces, very quickly.
One, state.
We all have had times, have you had
a time that you did something
and after you did it
you thought to yourself
I can't believe I said that,
I can't believe I did that.
That was so stupid, who's been there?
Say I.
(audience saying "I")
Have you ever done something
and after you do it you go
(clearing throat)
That was me.
(laughing)
Right, it wasn't your
ability, it was your state.
Your model of the world is
what shapes you long term.
Your model of the world is the filter.
That's what's shaping us.
That's what makes people make decisions.
We want to influence
somebody, we got to know
what already influences them.
And it's made of of
three parts, I believe.
First, what's your
target, what are ya after?
Which I believe, it's not your desires.
You can get your desires to goals.
How many ever got a goal
into desire and though
is this all there is,
how many have been there?
Say I.
(audience saying "I")
So, it's needs we have.
I believe there's six human needs.
Second, once you know what the
target that's driving you is
and that you uncover it for the truth.
You don't form it, you uncover it.
Then you find out what's your map.
What's the belief systems that are telling
ya how to get those needs.
Some people think the
ways to get those needs
is to destroy the world,
some people it's to build something,
create something, love someone.
And then there's the fuel you pick.
So, very quickly, six needs,
let me tell ya what they are.
First one, certainty.
Now these are not goals or
desires, these are universal.
Everyone needs certainty that they
can avoid pain and at
least be comfortable.
Now, how do you get it?
Control everybody, develop a skill,
give up, smoke a cigarette?
If you got total certainty ironically,
even though we all need that,
like, if you're not
certain about your health
or your children or money,
you don't think about much.
If you're not sure the
ceilings going to hold up,
you're not going to listen to any speaker.
But while we go for certainty differently,
if we get total certainty, we get what?
What do you feel if you're certain?
You know, what's going to happen,
when it's going to happen,
how it's going to happen,
what would you feel?
(audience shouting out)
Bored out of your mind,
so God in her infinite wisdom
(laughing)
gave us a second human
need which is uncertainty.
We need variety, we need surprise.
How many of you here love surprises?
Say I.
(audience saying "I")
Bull shit, you like
the surprises you want.
(laughing)
The ones you don't want you call problems,
but you need them, so
variety is important.
Have you ever rented a video or a film
that you've already seen, who's done this?
Get a (blanked out) life.
(audience laughing)
Alright, while your doing it,
you're certain it's good
because you've read it before,
saw it before, but you're hoping
it's been long enough you've
forgotten it, that's variety.
Third human need, critical, significance.
We all need to feel
important, special, unique.
You can get it by making more money.
You can do it by being more spiritual.
You can do it by getting yourself
in a situation where you put more tattoos
and earrings in places
humans don't want to know.
Whatever it takes, the fastest way
to do this if you have no background,
no culture, and no believe in resources
or resourcefulness is violence.
If I put a gun to your head
and I live in the hood,
instantly I'm significant,
zero to ten, how high?
Ten.
How certain am I that you're
going to respond to me?
Ten.
How much uncertainty, who knows
what's going to happen
next, kind of exciting.
Like, climbing up into a cave
and doing that stuff
all the way down there,
total variety and uncertainty
and it's significant, isn't it?
So you're willing to
risk your life for it.
So, that's why violence
has always been around
and will be around unless
we a conscientious change
as a species.
Now, you can get
significance a million ways,
but to be significant you got
to be unique and different.
Here's what we really need,
connection and love, fourth need.
We all want it, most people
settle for connection
'cause love's to scary,
don't want to get hurt.
Who here has ever been hurt
in an intimate relationship?
Say I.
(audience saying "I")
If you don't raise your hand you lie
about other shit too, come on.
(audience laughing)
And you're going to get hurt again.
Aren't you glad you came
to this positive visit?
(audience laughing)
But here's what's true, we need it.
We can do it through
intimacy, through friendship,
through prayer, through walking in nature.
If nothing else works for you, get a dog.
Don't get a cat, get a dog
'cause if you leave for two minutes
it's like you've been gone for six months
when you show back up again
five minutes later, right?
(audience laughing)
Now, these first four needs,
every human finds a way to meet.
Even if ya lie to yourself, even if ya
have split personalities.
But the last two needs,
the first four needs
are called the needs of the personality,
it's what I call it.
The last two are the needs of the spirit.
And this is where fulfillment comes.
You won't get fulfillment
from the first four.
You'll figure a way, smoke, drink,
do whatever, meet the first four,
but the last two, number
five, you must grow.
We all know the answer here,
if you don't grow you what?
If a relationship is not growing,
if a business is not growing,
if you're not growing.
It doesn't matter how much money you have,
how many friends you have,
how many people love you,
you feel like hell.
And the reason we grow, I believe,
is so we have something to give of value.
'Cause the sixth needs is to
contribute beyond ourselves.
'Cause we all know, corny as it sounds,
the secret to living is giving.
We all know life's not
about me, it's about we.
This culture knows that,
this room knows that
and it's exciting.
When you see Nicholas us here talking
about his hundred dollar computer,
the most passionate, exciting thing
is here's a genius, but
he's got a calling now.
You can feel the difference
in him and it's beautiful.
And that calling can touch other people.
In my own life, my life was touched
because when I was 11
years old, Thanksgiving,
no money, no food and
we're not going to starve,
but my father was totally messed up.
My mom was letting him
know how bad he messed up
and somebody came to the
door and delivered food.
My father made three decisions.
I know what they were, briefly.
His focus was this is charity.
What does it mean, I'm worthless,
What do I got to do, leave
my family, which he did.
The time, one of the most
painful experiences of life.
My three decisions gave
me a different path.
I said focus on there's
food, what a concept.
(laughing)
Second, but this is what changed my life,
this is what shaped me as a human being,
somebody's gift, I don't
even know who it is.
I thought, my father always
said no one give a (blanked out)
and all of a sudden somebody I don't know,
they're not asking for it,
just giving our family food,
looking out for us.
It made me believe
this, what does it mean?
That strangers care.
And what that made me decide
is that if strangers care
about me and my family, I care about them.
What am I going to do?
I'm going to do something
to make a difference.
So, when I was 17 I went
out one day on Thanksgiving,
it was my target for years,
have enough money, feed two families.
It was the most fun thing
I ever did in my life,
most moving, then next year I did four.
I didn't tell anybody what I was doing.
Next year eight, I wasn't
doing it for brownie points,
but after eight I thought (blanked out),
I could use dome help.
(audience laughing)
So sure enough, I went
out and what did I do?
I got my friends involved
and then I grew companies
and then I got 11 companies
and I built a foundation
and now 18 years later
I'm proud to tell ya
that last year we fed two million people
in 35 countries through our foundation,
all during the holidays,
Thanksgiving, Christmas,
in all the different
countries around the world.
(audience applauding)
It's been fantastic.
Thank you.
So, I don't tell ya that to brag.
I tell ya because I'm
proud of human beings
because they get excited
to contribute once they've
had the change to experience
it, not talk about it.
So, finally, and I'm about out of time,
the target that shapes you,
here's what's different about people.
We have the same needs, but are you
a certainty freak, is
that what you value most?
Or uncertainty?
This man here couldn't
be a certainty freak
if he climbed through those caves.
Are you driven by significance or love?
We all need all six, but
whatever your lead system is
tilts you in a different direction.
And as you move in a direction,
you have a destination or destiny.
The second piece is the map.
Think of that as the operating system
that tells ya how to get there
and some people's map is
I'm going to save lives
even if I die for other
people and there are firemen.
Somebody else says I'm going
to kill people to do it.
They're trying to meet the
same needs of significance.
Right, they want to honor
God or honor their family,
but they have a different map.
And there are seven different beliefs,
I can't go through them because I'm done.
The last piece is emotion.
I say one of the parts
of the map is like time.
Some people's idea of a long
time is a hundred years.
Somebody else says it's three
seconds, which is what I have.
(audience laughing)
And the last one I've already
mentioned that felt you.
If you've got a target, you got a map.
And let's say, I can't use
Google 'cause I love macs
and they haven't made
it good for macs yet.
So, if you use Mapquest,
how many have made
this fatal mistake of
using Mapquest at sometime?
(audience laughing)
You use this thing and
you don't get there.
Well, imagine if your beliefs guarantee
you can never get to where you want to go.
(audience laughing)
And last thing is emotion.
Now, here's what I'll
tell you about emotion.
There are 6,000 emotions
that we all have words for
in the english language, which is just
a linguistic representation, right?
It changes my language.
But if your dominate
emotions, if I had more time,
I have 20,000 people, or a thousand
and I have them write
down all the emotions
that they experience in an average week
and I give them as long as they need.
And on one side they're
writing empowering emotions,
the others disempowering.
Guess how many emotions people experience?
Less than 12.
And half of those make them
feel like (blanked out).
So they got five or six good
freakin' feelings, right?
It's like they feel happy, happy excited.
Oh, (blanked out) frustrated, frustrated,
overwhelmed, depressed.
How many of you know somebody
who no matter what happens
finds a way to get pissed off?
How many knows somebody like this?
(audience laughing)
Or no matter what happens,
no matter what happens,
they find a way to be happy or excited.
How many know somebody like this, come on?
When nine one one happened,
and I'll finish with this,
I was in Hawaii.
I was with 2,000 people from 45 countries.
We were translating four
languages simultaneously
for a program that I was
conducting for a week.
The night before was
called emotional mastery.
I got up, had no plan for this, and I said
we had all these fireworks,
I do crazy (blanked out),
fun stuff and then at the end I stopped.
I had this plan I was going to say,
but I never do what I'm going
to say and all of a sudden
I said "when do people
really start to live,
when they face death".
And I went through this whole thing about
if you weren't going
to get off this island,
if nine days from now
you were going to die,
who would you call, what would
you say, what would you do?
One woman, well, that night
was when 9-1-1 happened.
One woman had come to the seminar
and when she came there,
her previous boyfriend
had been kidnapped and murdered.
Her friend, or her new boyfriend,
wanted to marry her and she said no.
He said if you leave and
go to that Hawaii thing,
it's over with us, she said it's over.
When I finished that night, she called him
and left a message, true story,
at the top of the World
Trade Center where he worked,
saying "honey, I love you,
I just want you to know
I want to marry you, it was stupid of me".
She was asleep 'cause
it was three a.m. for us
when he called her back from the top
and said "honey, I can't
tell you what this means".
He said "I don't know
how to tell you this,
but you gave me the greatest
gift 'cause I'm going to die".
And she played the recording
for us in the room,
she was on Larry King later.
And he said "you're probably
wondering how on earth
this could happen to you twice".
And he said "all I can say to you is this
must be God's message to
you, honey, for now on
every day, give your all, love your all,
don't let anything every stop you".
She finishes and a man stands up
and he says "I'm from
Pakistan, I'm a muslim,
I'd love to hold your
hand and say I'm sorry,
but frankly this is retribution".
I can't tell you the rest
'cause I'm out of time.
(audience shouting)
Really, are you sure?
(audience applauding)
Ten seconds.
Ten seconds and I want to
be respectful, ten seconds.
All I can tell ya is that
I brought this man on stage
with a man from New York who worked in
the World Trade Center 'cause I had
about 200 New Yorkers there.
More than 50 lost their entire companies,
their friends, marking
off their palm pilots.
One financial trader, this
woman, made a steel balling,
30 friends crossing off that all died.
And what I did to people is said
what are we going to focus on?
What does this mean and
what are we going to do?
And I took the group and
got people to focus on
if you didn't lose somebody today,
you're focus is going to be
how to serve somebody else.
There were people, one woman got up
and she was so angry and
screaming and yelling.
Then I found out she wasn't from New York.
She's not an American, she
doesn't know anybody here.
I said "do you always get
angry", she said "yes".
Guilty people got guilty,
sad people got sad.
And I took these two men and did
what I call an indirect negotiation.
Jewish man with family in
the occupied territories,
some New Yorker who would have died
if he was at work that day
and this man who wanted to be a terrorist
and made it very clear.
And the integration that
happened is on a film,
which I'll be happy to send you.
So, you can really see
what actually happened
instead of my verbalization of it.
But the two of them not only came together
and changed their beliefs
and models of the world,
but they worked together to bring,
for almost four years
now, to various mosques
and synagogues the idea
of how to create peace.
And he wrote a book which is called
"My Jihad, My Way Of Peace".
So, transformation can happen.
So, my invitation to you is this,
explore your web, the web in here.
The needs, the beliefs, the emotions
that are controlling you, for two reasons.
So there's more of you
to give and achieve too.
We all want to do it, but I mean give.
'Cause that's what's going to fill you up.
And, secondly, so you can
appreciate, not just understand,
that's intellectual, that's the mind,
but appreciate what's
driving other people.
It's the only way our
world is going to change.
God bless you, thank you,
I hope this was served.
- Tony Robbins
(audience applauding)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed, this is
a test new series for us.
I'm curious what you think about it.
Should the Did You Know series continue?
Is there someone you'd like us to profile
in the next Did You Know series?
Let us know, did you hate this series
and never want to see it again.
Leave it in the comments below.
We're going to use your
feedback to make some decisions.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Jennifer Clarke.
Jennifer, thank you so
much for picking a copy up
of my book Your One
Word it really, really,
really, really means a lot to me.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love and I'll see ya soon.
(loud swooshing)